Okay, my name is Riley and I've been
trading for 9 years at this point. And
in this video, I'm going to give you the
13 most important trading lessons I've
learned over that time. It's not going
to be theory. It's not something that I
just pulled off the internet. These are
lessons from real trades I've taken,
real mistakes, blowing up accounts over
and over, and having to rebuild from
scratch, and finally figuring out what
worked for me. And also, from working
with thousands of traders and seeing
exactly where people get stuck and what
actually makes them succeed finally.
Now, I do want to say this before we get
into this. Some of these lessons might
challenge the way you've been thinking
about trading. They might go against
what you've been told or what you feel
like you should be doing to become
successful at trading. [music] But, I
can promise you this. If you actually
understand what I'm about to break down,
you're going to start looking at trading
a completely different way. Because over
time, what I've realized is there are a
lot of things in trading that feel
productive, but don't actually move you
forwards to becoming consistently
[music] profitable. And there are a
number of things that completely changed
everything for me, and that's what this
video is about and how it can do that
for you, too. Now, these 13 lessons all
really fall into [music]
three major groups. Because almost every
trader that is struggling right now is
stuck in one of these three areas. One
is why traders never actually improve,
why even with a good strategy, they're
actually still losing money, and what
actually makes someone start to become
consistently profitable. And underneath
all that, what you'll start to see is
that most traders are just stuck in a
couple of repeating cycles. So, whether
you're just beginning trading or you're
trader who's been struggling to make
money for years or someone who is
starting to make money, but you're stuck
in what is classified as a boom and bust
cycle. This is going to completely
change the way you approach trading and
if you actually implement this, it can
completely change your trading career.
Now, the first lesson here is simple,
but probably the most impactful and
where people lose the most money when
they first start out is trading is a
game of probabilities. And so, because
of that, some people when they first
start out, they can just get lucky and
go on a win streak. And what this does
is it [music] makes you feel confident
when really it's a false confidence that
gives you the ability to think that you
figured it out, you can now start to
size up. If you've ever heard of the
Dunning-Kruger effect, you're
essentially on the top of what's called
his Mount Stupid where your confidence
is really, really high, but your actual
experience and ability is really low.
And so, what happens is you can go on
win streaks. Like for me, I went on when
I first started certain strategies is I
would follow the strategy really well. I
would go on a win streak, make a lot of
money over a couple weeks because I was
following the strategy really well and
then so I would get really confident and
then I would start to think, "Okay,
well, I've mastered this. I can start to
increase my size. I can start to add
other types of trades to where I can try
and make more money because I've, you
know, I figured the market out." And
what ends up happening is you've just
hit the far end of the probabilities of
going on a win streak and then of course
at some point those probabilities have
to come back to the norm and you go you
start to lose money. And all of a sudden
you start to go on a losing streak
because you haven't built the experience
and knowledge to be able to handle that
and realize what you're doing is you're
starting to add more trades that aren't
actually successful and you're starting
to destroy your account because of that
initial lucky win streak. And I've had
people email me about losing thousands
or tens of thousands of dollars because
they size up too quickly. You do not
want to judge your trading ability off
of a small sample size. You really need
to be doing something like 20 to 40
trades and going through months of
trading to even have a decent idea of
your ability. So now that you have
learned a strategy and started to lose
with it consistently, you start to
think, "Okay, well, I need to just learn
more about the market and find something
that will improve my win rate. Try a new
strategy maybe because this one's not
working out." And so this is what gets
you stuck in the first major cycle that
can keep traders and kept me trapped for
years to be honest. And how it works is
you learn a new strategy because there's
so many on the internet. Basically,
there's infinite possibilities and ways
to trade because there's so many
different markets, there's so many
different time frames, there's just
infinite amount of information and
possible price movements the market can
have. You go learn a new strategy
because you think, "Okay, well,
logically in any other space in the
world, if you learn more, you're going
to get better at it." And with trading,
that's not necessarily true. But so you
learn a new strategy and you go and test
it out. Maybe have some success for a
couple weeks, but ultimately it doesn't
work out. And so then you start to say,
"Okay, I'm not getting the results I
want and so I need to go back to the
drawing board and learn a new strategy
because this strategy just doesn't work
for me or the strategy just sucks. And
that's a super logical, intelligent way
to approach trading of thinking that the
more you learn, the better you'll
become, but that's not how trading
works. What ends up breaking you out of
that cycle is realizing, and it took me
years to realize this, but simpler is
better. I went through so many ups and
downs of losing streaks, blowing
accounts, essentially hitting that wall
of so much struggle that I wanted to
give up. And so my last-ditch effort at
becoming successful was, "Okay, I'm
going [music] to think about what am I
actually good at with trading? What do I
feel confident in?" And my confidence
was that I am good at drawing,
essentially, support and resistance
zones. I'm good at big-picture looking
at where the market is potentially or
likely to reverse off of. And so I
thought, "Okay, how can I make a
strategy just focusing on that?" And
I've realized over time in teaching
other people and getting feedback from
other people, that is the real edge in
trading. One strategy, one pattern that
you can really master. Instead of trying
to master 10 different strategies and
having a ton of indicators or a ton of
patterns and a ton of signals, you focus
on mastering one thing. It's way easier
mentally to try and just master one
thing and repeat it over and over. When
you have that one edge you're focusing
on, it's way easier to execute on it,
track it, improve on the strategy that
you're doing, and consistently focus on
repeating it. I highly recommend is
trading one asset for this. Trade one
type of setup and trade, essentially,
just a short amount of time a day. I'll
talk about my strategy a little bit
later and how it kind of encompasses all
those ideas because what it does is it
it became super easy to consistently
repeat. And this kind of goes into
lesson four of don't try and master
everything. Don't try and trade stocks,
options, futures, crypto, and forex all
at once. Pick one asset. Literally focus
on one market. If it's just one stock,
it like if you just want to trade Tesla
all day on, do that. I only focus on
trading the S&P 500 futures, which is
just good for simplifying trading, but
also starting with a small account and
growing it. But essentially the idea is
because I watched this one asset day in
and day out for years, I have started to
master it and really understand how it
moves and flows. And this just allows me
to have such intuition now about what
happens that it feels like sometimes
that I have a crystal ball. I don't
necessarily make money off of every move
that I can see a potential happening
because that doesn't fit my strategy,
but very often I can be saying something
like in my trading room of oh, the
market looks like it's likely to do
this, like either break a support zone
or trend in a certain way, and you know,
20 minutes goes by and that read will be
correct. And of course, I'm not right
every day and I don't necessarily, you
know, have a crystal ball. Of course,
the market does things that I don't
understand all the time, but mastering
that one market has allowed me to have
such a confidence in reading it and my
ability to read it. And that's only
because I have focused so strongly on
one specific asset. And over the years,
I've tried to expand because I think,
okay, well, you fall into that trap of
if I can trade more assets, well, that's
more potential trades that show up. And
so, I've tried to expand the trading oil
or the Nasdaq sometimes or gold. I've
always tried those and ended up really
not making as much money and and losing
some money because I just don't know
those assets as well. And always just
coming back and focusing on one asset
has really been what's successful for
me. Because when it comes to trading,
how you really make money is scaling up
and increasing your trading size to
where, you know, you're not making $50
per trade. Now, you're making $5,000 per
trade. So, one of the biggest mindset
shifts that happened to me over focusing
on this stuff and what really helped me
break out of that initial losing cycle
of the learning loop was focusing on one
specific strategy, but also not trying
to catch every move. There's so much
movement in the market that you'll see
the market, you know, especially on a
volatile day, it'll go up, down,
sideways. It'll have a big move in one
direction. And you think when you are
looking at the charts, "Oh my god,
there's so much money to be made if I
catch every move. How can I do that?"
And I've tried to do that. I've tried to
shift my strategy sometimes to be more
aggressive to try and capture all those
moves. And what happens every time is I
just end up actually losing more money
instead of sitting and, you know, maybe
not taking a trade for a week or
multiple days, but when I do take a
trade, I'm way more likely to win. And
at the end of the day, all we're looking
for is a profit graph to consistently go
up over time. And it's hard to not take
a trade and try and make money every
single day with trading, but over the
long run, it's not about every single
day. It's about just seeing whatever
makes that graph slowly move up. And a
lot of times, every person kind of needs
to go through that cycle of trying to
make more money consistently, but over
the years of me trying over and over,
I've always come back to taking trades
less often and just the best ones is
what has actually made me consistent
money over time. Even if that requires
me to wait multiple days or sometimes
even weeks for trade to show up. Now,
all that's really helpful for breaking
out of that first cycle and finally
starting to focus on a strategy that
will consistently make you money. But a
lot of traders and what generally kicks
you back into that learning loop and
that initial losing cycle is they'll
find a strategy that really feels like
it works and it's really good, but
they'll still end up losing because even
once you start to stick to a strategy,
learning to master and becoming
consistently profitable with it is a
whole another losing cycle in itself.
Because the whole reason why someone
like me can be successful with a
strategy and if you try and execute it
the exact same way, you will still lose
money is because of what I call the
self-sabotage loop. If you've traded for
a while now and gone through ups and
downs, is you'll realize there's times
where you make emotional decisions in
trading [music] where you chase a trade
that ends up losing because really you
shouldn't have been in that trade to
begin with [music] and it didn't fit
your strategy. Essentially, the big
picture is your emotions derail your
ability to execute [music]
your strategy properly. The whole idea
is you have emotions that negatively
impact your trading.
>> [music]
>> And instead of entering in when your
strategy says you should, your emotions
essentially hijack your ability to
execute it properly. And so they control
your actions. And so the whole idea is
not letting something like nervousness
stop you from entering into out of trade
or FOMO making you jump in on a trade
that you really shouldn't because you
think the signal is there when it's
really not yet. And so all these
emotions [music]
affect everyone in slightly different
ways. And so you need to start to
[music] be aware of those and learn how
they affect your trading. Because what
you'll realize is you have essentially a
cycle of how these emotions consistently
over time repeat themselves. And so to
kind of give you an example of what my
self-sabotage loop looked like, I would
try and enter in a trade and every time
I would want to enter into a trade, it
would start off with when a trade signal
shows up, I would start to get fearful
because I would had the fear of being
wrong. You know, what if this trade,
even though the signal shows up, what if
this specific trade doesn't work out and
I lose money and I'm wrong. And that was
a big ingrained fear in my brain. And so
what that would cause me to do and how
it would affect my ability to trade, it
was I would skip [music] the trade out
of fear basically. And then so quite
often, because I my
>> [music]
>> my recognition of the strategy was good,
I would miss a winning trade. And so I
would get frustrated because, you know,
I've I just missed a winning trade when
I saw it. And in reality, I knew I
should have got in, but I got scared and
I skipped it. And so what that would
then cause is I would stay trading and I
would look for more setups cuz now you
know, I'm I'm pissed off, I've missed a
good trade. [music] I want to see if
another trade sets up that I can take.
And so I would then impulsively out of
FOMO now jump into a bad trade. You
know, the signal wouldn't quite be
there, but I thought, oh, this looks
good enough, I'll just get in because I
don't want to miss another trade that
ends up winning because then I'll be
really, really frustrated. And in the
end, what would happen is most likely
the trade turns into a loss because,
well, it wasn't a good signal. I jumped
in impulsively, [music]
too early, and then that would be turn
into more frustration. Honestly, most
likely at that point, I'd be a a little
more than frustrated, I'd be pissed off.
And I would either go into revenge
trading and take more losses. And you
know, start to go into one of those kind
of death spirals of uh trading account
profit graph, which doesn't look good.
Or I would, you know, force myself to
take a break. Either be done for the day
or done for the day and not trade the
next day because I'm just so frustrated
and [music] I've uh you know, I
realized, "Okay, I'm really emotional. I
need to take a break." And so, as
someone who is working to master a
specific strategy, you need to start
self-reflecting and realizing, "Okay,
what does my cycle look like? How do I
not let these emotions control my
actions?" Because that will really help
you break out of that cycle, that
self-sabotage loop, and become [music]
consistently profitable. And so, some
major lessons that kind of fall into
breaking that is a good trade is not the
same as a winning trade. This kind of
goes back even to lesson one where you
can go through a lucky streak of a bunch
of wins just because at the end of the
day, trading is probabilities. And a
small percentage of people will get
lucky over and over and over for a
while. But, just because they won
doesn't mean that they're actually good
trades and good entries. That's why
winning on bad trades is more damaging,
honestly, than taking a loss on a good
trade or even a bad trade. Because when
it comes down to it, you can take a
perfect trade that over the long run is
going to make you money and lose. And
you can take a terrible trade and win.
You can't judge your trades and how you
executed and entered in on them based on
their one singular outcome. Just this
past week, I had multiple trades that
went break even, but I think they were
perfect entries. Or even I'll have
sometimes losses where I think the entry
was great and I did nothing wrong. But,
once you're in a trade, the market can
do anything. No matter how perfect the
entry looks, there can just be news that
pops out all of a sudden, a tweet could
happen that just makes the market just
reverse in the other direction all of a
sudden and knocks you out at a loss.
That's why you can't get married to an
individual trade. Every successful
trader goes through losses. A lot of
good traders have like a 50% win rate. I
think mine is like 40%. The goal isn't
necessarily to be right every time,
which is really hard for a lot of
people, myself included. But, what your
goal is instead is to be focused on
executing your strategy successful every
time. That's what I see as a win. Those
trades that lost for me or become break
even, those are still successful trades
because I entered in when my strategy
said and I managed it how my strategy
said. I followed my plan to the T every
time because I know that that is what
successful over time. But, I could just
be on a losing streak based on
probabilities and how the market's
playing out at the time that that
happens. Yes, it's frustrating and I
have emotions that come up, but that's
why you want to realize them, don't let
them control your actions, and reset for
the next trading day. [music] And you
want to just focus on repeating what is
the essence of your trading strategy
because that's your edge in the market
over and over. And a big thing that I
realized over time and something that is
very important to realize is think of
position sizing as a dial of intensity
on your emotions. The smaller the size,
the less you're going to kind of care
about the trade and what happens. And
the bigger the size, the more you're
going to care about it. And so this
plays out in a lot of different ways and
will change over time as you grow as a
trader. Initially, maybe demo trading is
scary because you're trying to execute
your strategy. But over time, you get
used to that and so the dial kind of
gets lessened to where you start caring
a less and less because the intensity
isn't as much. You've adjusted to
essentially the intensity size that
you're at. And so this is where you want
to switch to real money. Even if it's
risking $30 per trade. That can, when
you first start out, is intense and
increases the intensity. But you [music]
care about the individual trade and are
focused in a productive way. And then
over time, that's how you scale up is
you can only increase your size when you
get used to the current size you're at
and you're emotionally ready to size up.
I wouldn't necessarily size up when you
go on a big win streak because again,
think about the probabilities is you
want to be able to handle a loss streak
at your size you're trading. That's the
true test of if you can handle the
trading size you're at. And if you can,
then increase your size a little bit to
again increase and go up that intensity
ladder of trading. That's how you scale
up over time. But that's the whole
reason why you can't jump up in size too
quickly is because you can't [music]
deal with it emotionally right away. You
want to wait until you get desensitized
essentially [music]
to the money on the screen. And so
anytime you're feeling more emotional,
it's okay to size down even for a day.
You know, if the market's just intense,
volatile, or you're on a loss streak,
it's [music] okay to size down for a
couple days until you regain that
confidence and then you can go back to
your normal size. Trading size is a tool
and so it's important to start using it
effectively. And so a huge mistake I see
a lot of people making, and for good
reason, is we all get into trading
really to make money. You know, trading
is very appealing for the ability to
make money in a short period of time. A
lot of people get into it with the idea
of having a daily P&L target. And
[music] this is extremely detrimental to
your trading because any strategy does
not work every single day. The market
goes through different cycles and
patterns. And so a strategy like mine
that is purely reversal focused has
times in the market where it can be
amazing for weeks and then the market,
let's say, just starts to go into a
massive trend and trends for weeks to
where reversals don't really happen. And
so for me, if I had a daily target P&L,
well, that would cause me to force
trades on [music]
let's say conditions that aren't
favorable for my strategy. And what that
would do is make it more likely for me
to lose. And instead what you want to be
doing is only executing your strategy
when the market is favorable for it. And
you don't know when that's going to
happen. It could be every day for a
while. It could be to where you have to
take a week or two between taking a
trade. Again, because the market has any
number infinite possibilities of what it
can do, you want to go and show up to
trading every day. If you're something
like me, I'm a day trader, I show up
every single day engaged and ready to
take a trade, but that does not mean I'm
going to take a trade that day or the
next day. I am there waiting to see if
my setup shows up. If it does, I
execute, and if it doesn't, I just move
on with my day. That's why for me, I
only trade like 60 minutes in the
morning because it allows me to just
show up, see if my strategy sets up, and
go about my day. If I had to sit in
front of the market for hours, which
I've tried, I've tried to trade for two,
three, four hours because logically you
think, "Okay, well, if I trade longer,
I'll get more trades because there's
more potential for trades to show up."
Which is true, but in reality, that
executing and doing that doesn't play
out because sitting there for hours on
end watching screens is boring at the
end of the day. And it allows you to
become more impatient over time. The
longer I'm sitting here staring at
charts, the more impatient I become, and
the more likely I am to force a bad
trade. And I think that applies to
pretty much everyone, which is why I
suggest trying to trade a short amount
of time or trade in increments. Trade
for an hour, then take a break for 20
minutes, and then come back and trade
for an hour. You want to always be
focused on executing your plan properly.
That is a winning day, not the outcome
or how many trades you took or the
profit you made of the day. And so, what
helps you find the real issues with your
trading and start to break out of that
self-sabotage loop is [music] journaling
your trades in some capacity. I think
it's important to track why you're
entering into each trade because that'll
help you realize, "Okay, am I entering
in because of my strategy tells me? Or
am I entering in because FOMO got me in
there?" And so, what you want to do is
write down why you got into a trade, you
know, based on the pattern. Even if you
FOMO in, there's always going to be a
pattern you're trying to follow. And so,
write down the pattern, but then also
the emotions you felt, even if it's,
"Oh, I was focused and locked in." Or I
was nervous. So many times for me, even
now, I jump into a trade and I'm nervous
to jump in. But, [music]
even though I'm nervous, now I've broken
out of that self-sabotage loop, I still
execute and don't let that nervousness
stop me from taking a trade. That's the
difference between old me [music] and
new me is old me would feel that scared
and nervousness and that doubt about the
outcome of the trade and skip it. But
now I realize it's okay to feel that
it's okay to be nervous on the outcome
because it's an unknown outcome and I'm
risking a lot of money on this, but I
jump in despite that because I know
logically that the reasons to jump in
are there. My strategy says to get in
>> [music]
>> and having an emotion and feeling an
emotion is okay. I just don't want it to
control my actions. And so, tracking all
that is extremely important because
you'll start to see your own patterns
over time and how your emotions
negatively affect your trading. And so,
you want to create rules to protect
yourself because [music] everyone's
different in how they react to certain
things and how your emotions cause you
what to do. And so, for me, what I did
when I had the issues of getting
frustrated and going on revenge trading,
I had a rule of I will only take a
maximum of two trades a day. I will take
uh
and if that means I take two wins or I
take two losses, I would always stop at
a maximum of two trades a day because if
you take two losses on a day, you're
most likely not seeing the market
properly. You're either uh trading
emotionally or not reading things
correctly or just the market's not
fitting your strategy that day and
really you should just call it anyway
because it's not a good trading day for
you. And on the flip side, having rules
to uh why to get in, you know, I try to
focus on only taking the best setups
possible, like what you could call an A+
setup. Because for me, I find that being
patient and waiting for the best setups
is what allows me to be confident in
executing them and be more profitable
over time. When it comes to trading,
it's very easy to know and spot what an
A+ setup is because usually it just
jumps right out at you.
>> [music]
>> And it's easy to spot what uh a horrible
setup is, you know, you you know when
it's obviously to not get in. The hard
part is dealing with those trades in
that gray area, where you start to say
things like, "Oh, I can kind of see it
working out." If you're starting to say
that in your mind, which is something
that I did, key into that and realize
that's kind of your brain trying to
mentally gymnastics you into a bad
trade. And because you kind of feel that
way, that's a signal that you should key
into that says, "Okay, I don't actually
have a solid read here. I should avoid
taking the trade." Because so many times
for me, that would be me jumping into a
weak signal and it would turn into a
losing trade. And another thing that
really helped me is kind of going back
to the amount you trade a day. I found
that after about an hour, I would start
to kind of you know, my eyes would gloss
over and I would get [music] bored or
want to force a trade because I've been
laser focused for last hour. And it's
hard to be really, really focused for
long periods of time because when it
comes to trading and watching the
markets, even if you're not doing
anything, you are making so many
decisions. Even if that decision is to
stay out of the market and do nothing
because there's just infinite patterns
and infinite outcomes of what's going
on. There's so much going on in your
brain that it is really mentally
draining. And it's hard to disconnect
the idea from, "Oh, the the longer I
work, the more money I make." And that's
usually correct for most jobs. But with
trading, that is not the case. I find
[music] that the less I do with trading,
the more money I make. If I trade for an
hour every day, I trade a lot better
because when it comes to trading, it's a
decision-making game. And so you have to
be making the best decisions you can
anytime you're trading. And me,
personally, I can't do that for 6 hours
when it comes to trading. And so that's
how I've created these rules over time
to protect myself from what I know works
for me and what doesn't. And again, this
is just stuff that you it takes time to
learn. That's why you can't become
successful with trading in a couple
weeks or a couple months. That's really
why it takes years to really master
trading and to be able to scale because
it's so much self-reflection
and understanding how you work and
[music] and deal with every situation
that comes up with trading. And it takes
so much time for all those situations to
come up, for them to repeat themselves,
and for you to learn how they work and
you work with them. Now, every trader
goes through rough patches, especially
when you're learning and going through
something like a boom-and-bust cycle.
You will go through drawdowns and
learning to deal with those and protect
yourself from those will help you
improve your profitability curve. I used
to go through a boom and bust cycle all
the time where I had I would go on a win
streak and then give it all back. And
this was a lot of because of that
self-sabotage loop, but I would [music]
get confident and then I would either
size up or the market would shift and I
wouldn't adjust to the market. And so
going through those rough patches you
need to have a plan of what you're going
to do. It's important to have things
like trying to reduce your trading size
until you build that confidence back up
and your trade start to win again
because there's no point in just blowing
through all your profits when things
don't seem to be working out. You can
cut your size in half and still make
good money if you're making wins, but
also you're not losing as much money.
You know, you don't [music]
as you see that profit graph go down, it
starts to affect you more and more
emotionally. And because of that, when
that happens, you have to start to
realize that, "Okay, I am not in a good
emotional state. I can't just be done
with trading for the day and reset by
the next day. I need more than one day
to reset." And so that's where sometimes
I would [music] take multiple days off.
I would just take the rest of the week
off. Whatever you need to reset. Again,
it's not [music] about trying to trade
every day. It's about showing up to
trading when you can make [music]
the best decisions possible. And if that
means you need to take a week off,
that's fine. Trading will always be
there.
>> [music]
>> More opportunities will always come. You
want to get out of the mindset of you
don't want to miss any opportunity that
shows up. That will really help you be
patient. And honestly, I would say the
number one thing that made me successful
and I see make other traders successful
is learning to be patient. Another thing
is if you start to expand and get overly
[music] confident and you know, say,
"Okay, I want to trade more markets now
or you know, new strategies." is cut
those out. The best way to improve your
trading is cut things away. Don't add
things, take things away and go back to
your bread and butter of what you were
successful with. Again, it goes back to
the whole idea of simple is better.
That's what has made me profitable and
what I've seen be more successful for
other people. They tell me all the time
that the way I approach trading and how
it's so simple and direct and specific
has changed the way that they view
trading and how their success has been
[music] with trading. And so, think
about where you are with all these with
where you are with these loops [music]
and start to think about how you can
break out of them and improve your
trading. If you want even more lessons
that I've learned over the years, I have
a free [music] 75 trading lessons PDF
that you can get via this QR code or
I'll leave a link in the description
below. And if you want to learn the
strategy that I've been talking about
that I use myself every single day and
that I've seen really help other traders
[music] simplify and focus on what's
important, check out this video right
here. I'll go into every detail on how
you can get started doing it and how you
can get started trading with just $4.